one more now on the breaking news from
police scotland that
uh two women and the man have died after
a series of incidents in kilmarnock last
night we can speak to
our scotland correspondent james
matthewson and james um
please say they're still looking into
the circumstances but we can assume
these incidents are linked
uh they are yeah they were very quick to
say that last night adam and indeed
they have confirmed that this morning
confirming details as well that three
people
have died it all happened in the space
of 45 minutes
last night at 7 45 in the grounds
of cross house hospital in coleman
that's about two miles from here
a woman aged 39 was found injured
and she died at the scene 20 minutes
after that
events took place here a woman aged
24 she was stabbed taken to hospital
having been found injured
but she died in hospital and then
shortly after that
a 40 year old male died in a serious
or fatal road crash not far
from here so you know some light shed on
the events of what happened
last night as you say the investigation
continues
into exactly importantly behind it but
police are stressing
that they are not looking for anybody
else in connection
with the events of last night reassuring
the public there is no danger
to them on the back of events here